I have a dream that's all I need
[Music]
how make mistakes but mistakes make you
strong hey guys I'm Daniel this is my
brother her new welcome to D LM model
lifestyle now this is our second video
in our new series called body
transformation from fat to fit in twelve
weeks in the last video we prepared you
guys and also had a new for this
upcoming 12-week body transformation and
this week we're gonna focus on the first
two weeks we're gonna look at the diet
plan and we're also gonna look at the
workout routine but before we go really
into it make sure that you've taken your
photos and your weight as well the same
we did with that
[Music]
[Music]
all right now the body transformation
from fat to fit in twelve weeks has
officially started so let's kick this
off now let's have a look at the workout
plan first
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
divide the cardio and the workout the
weight training right yeah so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna not have enough
time to do work for cardio and weights
in one session after work so what I'll
be doing is I'll try to put in the
cardio in the mornings before work I do
it on an empty stomach get the best on
that and then maybe do two works in the
afternoon but it's not necessary if it
doesn't work for your schedule you guys
can fit it both into one session often
work in the morning where hmm all right
so let's head to the gym to help you
guys and I haven't adapted new healthy
lifestyle we're not gonna throw you into
the deep end
so rather the start we're not going to
go too crazy at the gym because if we do
it will result in muscle soreness and
then you won't be able to go into the
gym for a few days and we do not want to
miss any days at the gym so the first
few days we're going to help you to
adjust more comfortably to the workouts
so that your body can keep up with this
schedule so first we're gonna do cardio
you'll do 15 minutes on the treadmill
where we are going to focus on your
heart rate while doing high-intensity
interval training also known as hit
Korea now doing the heat cardio burns a
lot more fat compared to normal
traditional cardio workouts and so we
will focus on it in most of our cardio
workouts alright so this is what you
need to do for the first week so first
we need you to warm up for three minutes
so start with a light jog or if you
cannot then just walk for three minutes
once you're done with the warmup you're
gonna change the speed to very fast or
thirty Seconds
then after that back to normal speed for
30 seconds to rest
[Music]
and then you just do this over and over
until you've read your 15 minute workout
[Music]
okay now for the weight training we're
going to switch between the circuit on
one day and hit cardio exercises on the
next so first we're going to go into
this circuit area so that we can show
you how to use the basic workout
machines after gym while you get a good
workout in the circuit works on the
timer so when the light turns green you
will hear a beep sound and you need to
start with your exercise you will then
hear another beep when you need to stop
the exercise now on the top corner we
will show you the name of the workout
and a picture to show you how to do it
if you're not sure but you can also look
at how hard you is doing all the
exercise
all right so how do you know what the
weight of the machine should be well you
have to adjust the weight so that you
can barely reach ten repetitions if you
can do more than twelve repetitions then
you know the weight is too light and you
should make it heavier on the other hand
if you can barely do four then you know
it is too heavy
next is shoulder press next up pictorial
also known as the vector
[Music]
all right next up leg curls
[Music]
next is total abdominal these are just
basic app crunches with machine
next up is the arm extensions these are
for your choices
[Music]
next is the leg extensions
[Music]
[Music]
as you can see how dinner's getting
tired already
next up LaRose
[Music]
next up like press with the machine
[Music]
next is the arm curls
the last one is the knee raises these
are for your lower abs remember to
crunch your abs when you bring your
knees up and breathe out
[Music]
all right
Abner has completed the whole circuit
and as you can see he's very tight but
you have to do the whole circuit one
more time and then you'll be done with
this workout now this is workout is from
Monday Wednesday and Friday
now we can move on to the next day so
the next workout routine is for Tuesday
Thursday and Saturday
now we know it's hard for parents to
come to the gym but hoddan he's really
putting in the effort
[Music]
all right so first we're gonna start
with heat exercises
[Music]
I'm gonna start with 10 burpees
[Music]
and rest for 30 seconds
[Music]
then second we have the Heinie's for 20
seconds if you can't do 20 seconds try
15
[Music]
rest 30 seconds again as you can see
have news already tired
next up is the mountain climbers you can
do this for 20 seconds again if you
cannot do 20 seconds try to go for 15
[Music]
then rest 30 seconds
[Music]
next up is the squat jumps you're gonna
try to do 10 of them if you can't do the
squat jumps
just try normal star jumps then you're
gonna rest 30 seconds and then we have
two ABS exercises the first one is a 90
90 crunch try to do 10 but if you can do
more go for it
then you can arrest like 30 seconds
[Music]
all right next up is the bicycles so try
to do ten of each side
all right that's it for the heat
exercises so next up we're gonna do the
cardio and we're gonna try
high-intensity interval training on a
bicycle
[Music]
all right so happen is just warming up a
little bit just three minutes and then
he's gonna switch over to heat Katya
she's gonna be 30 seconds up
high-intensity workouts and in 30
seconds up arrest you ready Adam II so
first you're gonna warm up for three
minutes and after that you're gonna go
hard and fast for 30 seconds
then you can arrest for 30 seconds
then we're gonna go hard and fast again
for 30 seconds and then rest again for
30 seconds
[Music]
now keep in mind the first few days of
these exercises might be very tough but
you'll get used to them as you go along
all right just so you guys know without
of the full workout for you everything
that I had no is doing in the video
description for you if you want to be
more specific and really want to know
what you should be doing and how you
should be doing and how much you should
be doing check it out
I don't know how did you feel after your
first week of workouts
well tiring I mean the first couple of
lines was tiring it was psyche but
afterwards rest of the week it started
getting better yeah folks felt the
muscles kind of coming alive again sigh
yeah right there yeah alright so let's
talk about the diet plan what changes
did we do well first of all we went to
the kitchen we took out all the
unhealthy stuff from the kitchen and had
a new and his wife Theresa they just got
a lot of healthy stuff and so that's
done that's the biggest change alright
and I hope you guys did the same now if
you're not sure what kind of food to eat
check out my diet plan video it will add
some extra things for you in the video
description that you can check out as
well but apart from that there's a few
basic big changes that we've also made I
don't know can you remember what those
are yeah so 5 major changes think well
first one is in Psych second one is
drink more water and then it's when to
eat as well not just eat whenever you
want the other one is basically I've
been approaching get rid of all the
unnecessary carbs fats and so on so in
more detail first one in psyche R so the
other is not even like a person that
would that's trying to be 120 kilograms
it's like the person want to be
synchronised doing a lot of water to get
that gets all the nonsense and so on the
planets on your system
third one is some twenty so so we went
with a intermittent eating plan
implemented fasting yes intermittent
fasting so yeah good idea they eat eight
hours as much as you want
to eat eight hours 16 hours of fasting
which helps a lot with cleaning up the
kitchen almost sites and then yeah other
than 80 minute fasting really what we
eat right like I said what you what you
eat is what you are so yeah around 30%
proteins really try to fight to take
that out a lot of that can it's just a
protein only diet and so on but we're
going for that healthy lifestyle so I
don't want to go for suicide after week
one just eating proteins and then carbs
and so on or I get to the gym and
actually do some jibbing they're very
crazy
yeah 30 percent proteins less carbs and
so on all of the sugars away yeah done
and then that sugar on yeah and then the
other big thing of course is supplements
getting really into the Apatow so I can
go to supplements with meals or when you
use yours or you get that shake yeah
yeah you guys remember hardener is doing
the us and body makeover challenge so
you can only use the products from us
and but we'll add a few other options
for you innovative description as well
it's not a sponsored video at all
alright so these are some of the basic
changes that we that we made and the
whole idea is to really get into this
healthy lifestyle do that let happen
adjust adapt to this new whole lifestyle
so it's gonna be okay if he still wants
to eat one or two unhealthy meals in the
week but as we progress in this 12-week
transformation it's gonna be a little
bit less alright so how has already been
making these healthy lifestyle changes
for one weekend so how do you feel after
this one week of eating healthier yeah I
feel good bit tired here and there and
so on but the changes to evening I think
that I think the biggest thing there is
the mental change I mean yeah so really
kind of realizing that eating healthy is
a thing I mean
yeah the planning and so on just just to
make sure that you keep that especially
at the beginning really incorporating it
my making part of daily life like like
making the bed every day just bringing
it's getting used to that happen bring
it in your life yeah so because change
is the other mental thing not just going
to the fridge whenever you want to grab
a grab something from the pop up back up
a chest when you feel like that so I'm
sorry you did mmm a lot of self-control
so let's keep a little bedless head to
this the the end of a second weekend
let's see how you did let's take his
measurements and his weight and have a
look
[Music]
all right four and a half kilos he lost
four and a half kilos in the first two
weeks how much did you guys lose let us
know in the comment section down below
we'd love to hear from you but I don't
know how did you feel about this whole
two weeks and not the results so yeah it
was tough it might have changed to get
into but I it feels right
I mean four or five kilograms losing
that that's a lot of extra baggage to
carry around yes that's that's actually
a V so feel good about that was a bit
tough I also got some flu first week so
I did turn it down a little bit and yeah
I had a relapse so the one night's ate
all the cookies for the sweets
everything in which auklets
cheese everything nice so yeah kind of
like a feeding frenzy but but yeah so
suffers through that but yeah got back
on the horse and so on so back into it
that's what it's important you might
happen with you guys as well but just
stay strong and just get back at it now
adapting to this new lifestyle brings a
lot of new challenges so with the gym
and adapting how to your workout
routines and everything how do you feel
about that yeah
actually much better at the beginning
was very tough but muscles feel a bit
stronger about to Soaring move and yeah
just a little full of that parrots can
actually run a bit more and so on my
treadmill so those given I think this
week going forward we're actually eating
weights and so on so happy to get into
that that's that's gotta be good yeah
the workout routine is gonna get a
little bit more intense and the diet as
well so subscribe and click the
notification bar so you won't miss the
next videos just guys
you